just a little bit more challenging is
that you have not just one radical but
you've got two radicals so what we're
gonna do is we're going to try to
isolate one of the radicals on one side
of the equation square both sides to
eliminate that radical but then we'll
still be left with another radical that
we have to isolate and then square both
sides again so let's go through this
example first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to square both sides okay
whatever you do to the left you want to
do to the right the square and the
square root cancel another out so we get
X plus 5 and then here what you have to
realize is that this is a binomial and
so when we square a binomial we actually
have to think about multiplying that
binomial times itself so you've got two
of them right so when you do this you're
gonna multiply the these two terms
together when you multiply a square root
times itself you just get what's
underneath so that's just gonna give you
the 3x minus 8 and then when you
distribute you get one square root of 3x
minus 8 plus another one times square
root of 3x minus 8 which is 2 square
roots of 3x minus 8 and then 1 times 1
gives you 1 so all I did was the foil or
you could think about doing the
distributive property twice okay once
with 3x minus 8 and then once with the 1
okay and that equals x plus 5
but now our goal is to get this square
root by itself on one side of the
equation so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say negative 8 plus 1 is negative
7 so we have 3x minus 7 okay
plus 2 times the square root of 3x minus
8 equals x plus 5 now what I'm gonna do
is I'm just going to subtract 3x and add
7 so subtract 3x and add 7 because our
goal is to try to get this radical by
itself so that's what we're heading
towards right now and as long as you do
the same thing to both sides you keep
this equation balanced I'm going to
divide everything by 2 okay so that
gives you square root of 3x minus 8
equals negative x plus 6 and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
square both sides to get rid of the
square root okay so those cancel one
another out we get 3x minus 8 and then
again we're left with a you know
binomial times a binomial so I'm just
going to write it twice and we can foil
or do the distributive property twice so
negative x times negative x is positive
x squared that's negative 6x and another
negative 6x and then a positive 36
okay equals 3x minus 8 so now we're
going to subtract 3
and add 8 to both sides so subtract 3x
and add 8 to both sides and we're just
trying to set it equal to zero get
everything on one side okay so this is
going to be let me see this is going to
be negative 12x minus 3x is negative 15
X plus 44 and then what we can do is we
can factor this what multiplies to 44
but adds to 15 that's a negative 11 and
negative 4 and if you say each group to
0 you can see that x equals 11 or 4 but
remember when you work with radical
equations you always want to check your
answer because sometimes you get
extraneous roots you know false answers
so you want to just double checks when
take those those numbers and put them
back into the original equation so let's
go ahead and put 11 back into the
original equation what was the original
equation it was square root of 3x minus
8 plus 1 equals a square root of x plus
5 okay so if we put 11 in we get 3 times
11 is 33 minus 8 is 25 the square root
of 25 is 5 plus 1 is 6 and then if we
put 11 on the right side 11 plus 5 is 16
square root of 16 is 4 6 does not equal
4 which means that 11 is an extraneous
root you can just cross that one out
that one doesn't work if we try 4 we get
3 times 4 is 12 minus 8 is 4 square root
of 4 is 2 plus 1 and then over here 4
plus 5 is 9 square root of 9 is 3 3 does
equal 3
so this is a good answer so you want to
check sometimes you get no solution you
get 2 solutions you get one solution it
just depends but you want to take those
answers put them back into the original
equation make sure you don't have an
extraneous root there so that's how you
work with a little bit more challenging
radical equation like we did in this
example subscribe to the channel
check out more math videos on Morrow's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I
look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon